that's a good question the prize makes
it harder to leave the academic world
but but about every seven years I have
an itch to try something new and I one
of my fears with the prizes that is that
you get complacent and I always want to
be pushed and scared because I feel I'm
most productive when I'm scared about
being able to provide for my family or
do whatever I think that's when the
creativity is the highest why I feel
like I have probably about two or three
more years I've been actually working on
other microscopes so since 2008 are
about four or five years ago I stopped
doing the work that led me to the prize
because I was frankly bored of it and so
I've been working on other kinds of
microscopes and answer other kinds of
questions but i think i have about a
couple more years of that before i'm
said everything I have to say about
microscopy and I honestly like to go
work for one of the private space
transportation companies if I could